all right I quickly want to talk about
kind of the interaction with corporation
company reps at these conferences
because to me it's still a bit of a
secret or a bit of a not really clear of
what to do there's very different kinds
of companies at these conferences so
some companies I feel are there to
basically show off their technology kind
of wanting you to use it
one example is for example graph core
they're kind of new kid on the block for
AI hardware in that they claim to have a
chip specifically designed for the types
of operations that machine learning
applications do so even more specialized
than a GPU and also they claim they are
faster for equivalent kind of money
spending than an NVIDIA GPU like a
classic GPU so basically you get much
more bang for the buck now for now they
just offer a cloud solution I believe
and they're gonna sell their their cards
through Dell the way it works is to have
kind of a low-level compiler that will
compile your model to these cards and
for now you can interact with it through
C++ and then tensorflow will come later
something like this thing about their
card is that they have an extremely
large memory right next to the to the
compute Unix
this would be kind of your traditional
level one cache yeah so
that means that you get much faster
access technically to your local
variables but then they don't have any
kind of RAM which means they're like
entire card only has somewhat like 300
megabytes of memory but they claim they
can just basically distribute if you
have a large model you can distribute
that over many cards and then it you'll
get it you'll get basically the speed up
of the cards without having to sacrifice
a model size another company that shows
off really cool technology is a company
that does lidar and I forget the name
right now but when I try to look it up
they so they do a lidar sensor basically
that is super tiny and it costs a
fraction of like a traditional lidar
sensor so I think they said there's cost
about twelve thousand dollars and it's
really tiny and as a couple of
advantages compared to traditional
centuries as far as I understand their
lasers are mounted on the same chip so
they always point in the same direction
which reduces a lot of inaccuracies so
if you know I guess people who would be
interested in that you know from
self-driving cars and so on
these are kind of the hardware
demonstrations that I've seen then
there's other things like there is a
Wellness Center where you can get a
massage which is sponsored by the big
companies which is pretty nice but I'm
not I'm probably too much I don't I
don't like these kinds of things too
much
maybe I'm just socially too awkward yeah
for some companies I feel that they're
just there to recruit and they don't
really want to want to talk about what
they do too much so this this would be
an indication of this would be a company
where basically all of the all of the
reps at the booth are recruiters so not
non-technical recruiters and that
basically just kind of tell you what you
can do as a career and not really what
the the company does as a whole so um I
never really know what to talk about
then because I don't feel like most
people are interested and drawn towards
interesting work and if that comes with
good working conditions then that's a
plus but I don't feel for many people
that that is the most important thing
though I could be wrong and probably
it's good that for some people it is
because otherwise everyone would take my
jobs the ones that I like yeah so these
companies will usually if there is an
engineer they'll not talk about too much
what they do like ours company secret
and so on so the funniest one was
actually the NSA - the NSA it was kind
of painful because
you kind of ask them so what do you do
and they're like yeah machine learning
like are there any you know because what
I want to know as a researcher right is
like is there anything I could do there
that I couldn't do anywhere else right
so is there any these are any unique
problems that the NSA faces that
actually demand new research like demand
new machine learning methods or or you
know some kind of change ask they seem
like yes there are problems like this
and you ask like which problems and
they're like yeah yeah there are
problems we can't tell you so
everything's basically whatever I made
it a game to like ask the more specific
questions and watch them like oh this is
classified so yeah if you're here
definitely check them out it's it's a
fun it's just fun to talk to them yeah
so I feel to most most companies they're
really interesting I don't know more
than half of them so just going up ask
them what they do
just get an overview over the landscape
of what's neat is currently in machine
learning research I think that's really
useful because as an academic I tend to
be very disconnected from the from the
industry side of things and from what
people actually need or want in practice
so talking to all these companies is
really helpful to get an overview over
that yeah so but if you know if you know
a better way I know people some people
are much more successful than me talking
to companies at conferences I'm
definitely not the best at this and if
you have a better strategy let me go I'm
pretty happy so far all right